after the high drama of Harry's book a
low-key arrival in Manchester the Royal
Train bringing the king for his first
trip aboard as monarch and to Kellogg's
Europe's biggest Cereal Factory he'd
come for the company's UK Centenary but
revealed he was a little late
[Music]
and then to Bolton joining Camilla for
their first appearance together since
spare was published I don't know how he
feels but it must be really hard for his
dad to walk around the king to walk
around like that with a smile on his
face and hoping nobody's going to
question him about it because I said to
the king your mum came in 1988 and
really inspired me so it's lovely having
you here today we go down to London we
went down for the Jubilee we went down
to lay flowers down for the queen as
well and we bought to go to the
coronation so to have them come up here
to like kind of to us so I think yeah
it's great it's fantastic it does mean a
lot probably more than they realize
the king and queen consort back on the
beat together Keen to carry on and even
Keena to move away from the Fallout from
Harry's memoir
anybody read Harry Potter these are the
book chats Camilla enjoys meeting
children and talking authors and for the
king England's Monarch met England's
manager Gareth Southgate an ambassador
for the prince's trust and of course
helping get the king's message back on
the front foot Laura bundock Sky News
Bolton